We all know that words change their meaning according to the context they're used in.
This change in meaning can sometimes be quite significant.
The word pitch, for example, can be used to refer to the field area available...
...for playing football or cricket.
However, in phonology, it is the range of voice level available through the vocal cords.
As language users, it is important for us to understand...
...how words are used differently in different situations.
The understanding that language usage adapts to the context and environment...
....leads us to the broader definition of the word language,...
....which we linguists prefer.
This definition is not restricted to the 6,000 distinct communication systems...
....including key languages such as English, Chinese and French.
It includes any form of speech within these categories, including dialect.
Dialect, by the way, is the variety of a language used in a particular part of a country.